der erfolg hat viele väter wie man so
schön sagt beim wahlerfolg der spd
scheint die vaterschaft ausnahmsweise
ziemlich eindeutig das liegt wohl auch
daran dass ein sozialdemokratischer
kanzlerkandidat dieses mal unbehelligt
von seinen partei linken wahlkampf
machen konnte daher löst der olaf scholz
jetzt eigentlich politisches
schmerzensgeld an die linden entrichten
doch allen klingt noch sein satz im ohr
wer bei mir führung bestellt bekommt
führung
auf dem weg ins kanzleramt hat scholz
die spd im griff jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio cerstin gammelin
ist bei uns die stellvertretende chefin
des parlamentsbüros der süddeutschen
zeitung hier in berlin anna battke ist
redakteurin korrespondentin im berliner
büro der neuen zürcher zeitung und
zugeschaltet sind uns der kommunikations
und politikberater klaus peter schmidt
dem geld und der publizist und autor
hugo müller vogg frau gammelin olaf
scholz und die spd ist das eine
politische solidargemeinschaft oder ist
das ein zweckbündnis anders auf jeden
fall zweckbündnis aber da haben sich
glaube ich im letzten sommer dann zwei
gefunden eine linke die nicht ganz
untergehen wollte und ein kanzler und
ein sagen wir mal zentrist der gerne
kanzlerkandidat werden wollte und die
beiden haben sich verbündet ein
gemeinsames programm geschrieben und in
der tat man glaubt es kaum dass bis zum
schluss durchgehalten
müller vogg muss die partei linke nicht
scholz gewähren lassen um eine möglichst
lange spd kanzlerschaft
sicherzustellen
sowie die parteilinke weiß natürlich
sehr genau dass sie diesen wahlerfolg
erster linie scholz zu verdanken habe
und es sich auch viele ins parlament
gekommen die gar nicht damit gerechnet
hatten dass das überhaupt klappen könnte
sigmar gabriel hat neulich mal gesagt
bei der spd sei es so wenn einer eine
wahl gewinnt dann ist gibt die partei
zunächst mal anderthalb jahre ruhe und
freut sich über den sieg aber spätestens
dann werden die die mit dem kurs nicht
einverstanden sind sich zu wort melden
und das vermutlich wollen wird hier
ähnlich sei es mit dem geld wie
lernfähig ist eigentlich die spd wenn
man zum beispiel an die jahre
1982 und 2005 denkt wo jeweils die
kanzler helmut schmidt und gerhard
schröder unter kräftiger mithilfe vor
allen dingen der parteilinken auf ihr
amt verzichten mussten bzw ihr amt
verloren haben
gut das sind völlig andere leute und ich
wage keine prognose wie viel
historisches wissen die jungen leute die
jetzt in der fraktion sind haben werden
aber eins ist klar es waren völlig
andere situation damals war die spd eine
volkspartei mit dem anspruch auch wieder
stärkste partei zu werden
heute weiß man dass man fast aus dem
nichts kommt das diszipliniert und das
wird auch die parteiführungen den jungen
leuten beibringen dass jetzt nur
geschlossenheit hilft und alles was ich
vernommen habe auch am wahlabend und
danach aus dem spd bundesvorstand ist
das so dass da jetzt disziplin das erste
gebot ist und das zweite gebot ist
nochmal disziplin dass das auf dauer so
bleibt ist sicherlich keiner partei zu
sagen aber ich würde mal um dann müller
vogg zu antworten sagen in der cdu wird
das sehr viel schneller passieren dass
da alle durcheinanderreden und was
anderes wollen das hat ja schon
angefangen so dass die spd hier in einer
guten ausgangsposition ist
es sind viele neue leute in der
spd-fraktion im bundestag die junge
menschen
49 also das ist etwa ein viertel der
gesamtfraktion vor allen dingen
jungsozialisten ich nehme mal an dass
das in der tat auch idealisten sind die
vielleicht mit den parlamentarischen
gepflogenheiten noch nicht so vertraut
sind klaus peter schmitl geld sagt ja
gerade da ist jetzt disziplin
erforderlich wie muss denn olaf scholz
mit diesen vielen neuen umgehen ja das
wird noch eine spannende entwicklung
sein denke ich also die die
unerfahrenheit allein kann man jetzt
glaube ich nicht zum vorwurf machen aber
was er tatsächlich interessant ist dass
ein viertel der abgeordneten unter 30
jahre alt ist und das kräfteverhältnis
sich hier etwas verschieden wird und die
jusos sind jetzt nicht dafür bekannt
besonders
etabliert und konservativ zu sein und so
haben eine sehr radikale ausrichtung und
das wird noch die nummer leute und mafia
die sind auch nicht sehr handzahm ich
meine olaf scholz kommt ja selber aus
der user weiß dann vielleicht wie man
das vermitteln kann aber ich sehe da
noch ein großes konfliktpotenzial aber
im moment um wieder zurückzukommen auf
ihre ausgangsfrage
kriegt er das ja noch ganz gut hin die
befriedung nach innen also da halten
noch alle die füße stehen wir auch schön
blöd bin nicht dass ich da jetzt zwei
gefunden haben soll zwei eigentlich ne
der ist der dritte
navarro und herrscher sein also dass ich
meine scholz und die spd auf den zukauf
die auf die er auf die eingangsfrage da
haben sich also scholz die spd gefunden
wenn man etwas flapsig gesagt es hat
geklappt weil die linken die klappe
gehalten haben aber was folgt da jetzt
raus aus dieser geklappt mit dem weise
mit mit dieser konstellation was macht
die spd was macht auch stolz darauf also
ich würde einmal die theorie wagen das
hat nicht geklappt weil die die klappe
gehalten haben sondern das hat einfach
aus brutaler alternativlosigkeit
geklappt weil alle eingesehen haben olaf
scholz ist der einzige mit dem wir
losziehen können und weil scholz sich
auch auf die linke zu bewegt hat also
wer das wahlvolk haben sich anschaut
dass sie dann schon wirklich ein
sozialdemokratisch links ausgerichtet
links ausgerichtetes wahlprogramm mit
sehr viel sozialpolitik stichwort
mindestlohn stichwort rente stichwort
gesundheitssystem also da ist schaut
schon auf die zugegangen und die linken
haben natürlich ihre wünsche dann
teilweise auch mit untergebracht
ich glaube die erste hürde wird heute
bespringen müssen wenn er eine ampel
verhandelt wenn er natürlich der fdp was
geben muss wenn er auch den grünen was
geben muss und dann seine eigenen partei
sagen muss leute das wäre der vertrag
und wir kriegen nicht alles durch aber
bitte stimmt so aber deswegen wenn sie
sagen im wahlprogramm stehen ja schon
viel linke ist aber das muss ich ja dann
im koalitionsvertrag finden sonst wird
es ja nicht praktische politik das
stimmt aber ich glaube nicht dass er das
die spd 12 wahlprogramm
das ist das wichtigste wie der
mindestlohn sein
das ist glaube ich auf den ersten blick
auch der der große spagat mit der fdp
weil die ja nicht staatlich geregelte
löhne haben wollen und ich glaube schon
dass da auch kompromisse möglich sind
dass man eben zum beispiel die
berechnungsformeln so ändert dass er
demnächst auf 12 euro steigt also ich
denke das ist möglich klaus peter
schmitl geld sie haben ja spd politiker
auch beraten wie hans eichel und walter
riester kennen die partei auch sehr gut
gibt es denn bei den linken in der spd
da die einzig dass scholz seine position
die art zu politik zu machen und auch
seine inhalte die er jetzt nach vorne
rückt das die einfach politik und
mehrheitsfähiger sind als die positionen
der linken die es im weiteren jahr
besonders häufig gibt
also grundsätzlich ja die sind ja nicht
dumm das sind junge leute die was
gelernt haben in der regel und die
wissen wie
kompromisse auch notwendig sein werden
und wer man kevin kühnert hat der ja
sozusagen das sprachrohr dieser jungen
leute dann auch in der fraktion und nach
wie vor dem parteivorstand ist dann hört
man ja und sieht man ja dass da genau
das verstanden ist und wenn man das
beispiel mindestlohn and bass casting
bei den gerade
aufgeworfen hat dann ist das sicherlich
ein knackpunkt aber ich sage mal über
vier jahre kann man ja auch eine
steigerung eine stufenweise regelung
finden man kann auch den tarifparteien
ein jahr zeit geben um das zu regeln
alles das ist verabredeter und einer
solchen regelung könnte meines erachtens
auch die fdp zu stimmen also das ist
jetzt in der tat wirklich einen
sondieren was geht was geht mit welchen
schritten und gibt es hürden die
unüberwindbar sind ich sehe die aber
nicht wenn man weiß was auf dieses land
zukommt und was an problemen zu lösen
ist und selbst die industrie fordert ja
jetzt dass da schnell was passiert und
wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe so die
meisten industrie bosse und die meisten
chefs der meinung dass eine ampel
koalition jetzt das wäre was das land
voranbringt darf ich noch vielleicht
ganz kurz nachfragen weil sie gesagt
habe die einzig bei den linken der spd
ist da durchaus da das jetzt
pragmatismus trumpf ist dass man sich
einigen muss das kompromisse nötig sind
das habe ich das interpretiert aber
würde das bedeuten dass saskia esken und
kevin kühner dann ihren überzeugungen
untreu werden kevin kühnert hat ja vor
nicht allzu langer zeit weil sie gerade
die wirtschaft angesprochen haben die
verstaatlichung von bmw zum beispiel des
bmw konzerns gefordert
ja das wird ja auch mit weder mit olaf
scholz noch mit der fdp noch mit den
grünen durchsetzen das sind wahlkampf
sprüche und sie sind in der realität
angekommen
da sieht man jetzt ja auch also das wird
glaube ich nicht auch sein was die linke
jetzt ist ins koalitionsprogramm
schreiben will da habe ich wenig sorge
davor glauben sie denn dass die spd sie
habe jetzt gesagt anderthalb jahre so
ein zitat von sigmar gabriel in einem
der früheren spd-vorsitzenden halten die
still und dann geht es los und dann wird
sozusagen wird dann sozusagen die linke
politische dividende eingefordert so
habe ich das jetzt verstanden
glauben sie dass das quasi zwanghaft
eintritt oder dass die spd an aufgrund
der alternativlosigkeit dieser politik
die ja scholz sogar präsentiert
vielleicht nicht doch da bei der stange
bleiben sehr gut ist weil es einen
koalitionsvertrag
abgeschlossen werden in dem
koalitionsvertrag müssen sich alle drei
parteien wiederfinden die grünen werden
großen wert darauf legen dass bereich
klima politik sie ihre handschrift
hinterlassen
die fdp wird im bereich wirtschaft und
finanzen darauf pochen dass sie
erkennbar sind und die spd auch beim
sozialen schauen was da kommt nur weil
eben die rede war von wahlkampf sprüchen
olaf scholz hat im wahlkampf gesagt mit
mir als kanzler wird ist im ersten jahr
ein mindestlohn von 12 euro geht also
diese frage ob das im laufe der zeit
kommt wenn diese kommission die aus
gutem grunde eingesetzt wurde damit
mindestlöhne nicht sozusagen im
wahlkampf ausgehandelt werden sondern
von den tarifvertragsparteien dass diese
kommission im laufe der nächsten jahre
den mindestlohn ohnehin anheben wird das
ist ja unbestritten aber ist ein
unterschied ob ich im wahlkampf sage im
ersten jahr gibt es 12 euro mit mir als
kanzler das hat er mehrfach so gesagt da
ist es schwierig wieder runter zu kommen
wobei ich der meinung bin dass die fdp
mit dem mindestlohn von 12 euro
dr ein handeln kann gegen den verzicht
auf die vermögenssteuer und gegen den
verzicht auf eine verschärfung der
erbschaftssteuer
aber trotzdem liege wird von anfang an
schon darauf achten dass einige ihrer
auszuschließen ist angles durchaus da
betrieb bleiben ja ich glaube der euro
der zwölf euro mindestlohn ist nicht
verhandelbar also das wäre das sein was
die spd durchsetzen muss und die
vermögenssteuer glaube ich wird da er
drauf kind eine umfrage unter
cdu-anhängern dass selbst die cdu
anhänger zu 70 prozent für solch einen
mindestlohn von zwölf euro sind ob die
werden jetzt darüber geredet was die
linke an zugeständnisse machen muss für
olaf scholz damit er auch richtig
regieren kann damit erst mal eine
koalition zustande kommt und dass er
dann auch seine politischen ziele
umsetzen kann jetzt sehen wir das mal um
was muss olaf scholz denn tun in der
koalitionsvereinbarung später in der
praktischen politik also im
regierungsalltag um die linken bei laune
zu halten die in seiner partei die
mehrheit darstellen ja das ist für mich
wirklich eine interessante frage also
ich würde aber erstmal noch mal
widersprechen dass also ich glaube es
tat im wahlkampf von olaf scholz schon
ganz gut dass sehr wenig zu hören war
von saskia esken und kevin kühn hat und
die waren dann so im hintergrund aber
die sind ja nicht weg und auch auch
diese junge linke generationen die ist
ja auch nicht weg ob das jetzt schon
eine rolle spielen wird für die
koalitionsverhandlungen
da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher weil
das erst mal alles gemacht werden muss
und alle stehen unter zugzwang alle
haben gelernt aus 2017 hoffentlich aber
für die künftige politik wenn es dazu
kommen sollte dass olaf scholz ins
kanzleramt zieht und ministerposten
besetzt werden ich finde dann wird es
richtig interessant wer kommt denn dann
dafür von den jusos und die bringen die
sind jetzt sehr jungen die bringen oft
universitären hintergrund mit und auch
diese ganze identitätspolitik die meines
erachtens die linke auch sehr gespaltet
hat also nicht nicht nur in der
sozialdemokratie und auch nicht nur in
diesem land und da wird dann wird es
glaube ich noch sehr harte kämpfe und
aushandlungsprozess gegeben und scholz
ist ja angewiesen auf die also rein
quantitativ haben die ich glaube ich
habe ungefähr 50 sind sie dann er
braucht sie und er kann nicht seine
realpolitik das sehe ich nicht dass er
die einfach dann so durchsetzen kann wie
es ihm gefällt
ist dass die schwierigkeit bei diesem
wir wollen wir jetzt den
regierungsalltag ansehen und wir die der
untertitel der sendung ist er hat scholz
die spd im griff heißt ja er hatte die
spd an ihm zu verdanken diesen
politischen erfolgt dass sie jetzt die
führende regierungspartei wird auf der
anderen seite hat er 206 abgeordnete die
mit ziehen müssen mit den anderen
koalitionsfraktionen sonst wird es mit
den gesetzen und auch freilich mit den
reformen nichts diese ambivalenz die
wird ihm erhalten bleiben wie wird er
damit umgehen wir kennen ihn ja jetzt
vom wahlkampf scholz hat ja wegen scholz
wahrscheinlich gewonnen der art wie er
das macht
kann man das so fortsetzen fortschreiben
in die in den regierungsalltag ja ich
glaube also erst mal vielleicht nach dem
motto kevin kühnert ein kollege von mir
ist mit ihm im haustür wahlkampf
gegangen und hat wirklich flyer gehabt
wo vorne er und hin stolz drauf war also
da hat man sich schon irgendwo
angenähert glaube ich und ich denke er
wird den linken natürlich was geben
müssen es würde mich nicht wundern wenn
zum beispiel saskia esken die hat er ja
schon offiziell als ministrabel
bezeichnet dass sie irgendwo im
ministerium bekommt in ministerin wird
dann wäre sie schon mal eingebunden und
ich glaube auch dass ihm so wie man ihn
kennt wie man ihn kennen gelernt hat
dass er versuchen wird auch die linken
die jusos einzubinden und
umarme deine feinde so zu sagen na und
ich glaube schon dass er das war vom
schirm hat ja doch wieder um allein kann
ich nicht sagen ich umarme dich aber die
die vermögenssteuer bekommst du nicht um
eine umverteilung ist ja für die spd
doch ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt ist
ich habe selbst gesagt die spd ist nach
links gerückt mit das programm ist ein
anderes als das als das früher war
umverteilungen höhere steuern die oberen
fünf prozent kräftig belasten früher
sprach die spd war in
vorzeiten von die belastbarkeit der
wirtschaft testen so das kommt ja alles
wieder und dann muss er dann schon
einiges liefern zumal man ja auch davon
ausgehen muss dass ist einen
mitgliederentscheid geben wird und die
mitglieder die vor nicht allzu langer
zeit gesagt haben wir wollen kein olaf
scholz an der spitze der partei haben
die werden dann entscheiden und das was
er ausgehandelt hatten auch die
kompromisse aushandeln muss ob sie das
alles so gut also wenn ich da mal ganz
kurz noch mal was ein werfen darf die
spd war vor einem jahr sozusagen
klinisch tot mit 14 prozent sie hat
jetzt in einem jahr plötzlich fast 26
gekriegt als wahlkampf ergebnis damit
hat keiner gerechnet die ist mit 206
abgeordneten jetzt im parlament die
stärkste fraktion ich habe in der spd
sind im moment so viele einfach
glücklich froh und verwundert und
verstehen eigentlich gar nicht was
passiert ist dass ich nicht glaube dass
diese alten grabenkämpfe die sicher
irgendwann wiederkommen gar keine frage
aber dass das im moment und absehbaren
thema ist im moment sind die nur alle
froh dass sie wieder atmen können und
nicht mehr klinisch tot sind gut aber es
braucht auch eine neue
auseinandersetzung silber entschuldigung
in der sozialdemokratie wohin sie
eigentlich wollen also ich sehe das
schon eine große orientierungskrise kann
er sein jetzt dass die dass die freude
darüber groß ist aber was eigentlich was
ist mit der sozialen frage zum beispiel
dann geht es gab ja auch diese große
identitätsdebatte
ausgelöst durch den beitrag von wolfgang
thierse meiner meinung nach ist das in
der partei noch nicht richtig
aufgearbeitet worden wo die da
eigentlich stehen und was das bedeutet
für das alte kern klientel und die
sozialen fragen und eine eine schicht
nicht akademie siert ist und denen es
egal ist ob man jetzt die gender sprache
verwendet oder nicht den ist sie
überhaupt nichts mit postkolonialismus
und ähnlichen dingen was anfangen können
und das spielt ja das ist jetzt gerade
klar es ist ein bisschen zugedeckt aber
es ist doch da das ist doch ein thema
also besonders in der jungen generation
das mittel geld
ja also zwei punkte erstmalig selbst
wenn es einen mitgliederentscheid gibt
was ja nicht klar ist
ich hätte jeden betrag dass dieser
mitglieder bescheid entscheid für einen
koalitionsvertrag ausgeht was wäre denn
die alternative für die mitglieder und
für die fraktion ein urlaub scholz der
hinschmeißen würde eine spd die dann am
boden wäre wenn sie nicht
regierungsfähig wäre und man muss doch
auch mal das umfeld sehen also was
kerstin eben gesagt hat oder weil das
richtig verstanden habe
dann geht es ja hier nicht nur um die
identitätskrise in der spd die in der
union und das ist ja das umfeld die ist
ja noch viel größer auch die wird viel
größer werden was da jetzt an zerlegung
prozess erst begonnen hat der sich
fortsetzen wird das wird ja auch die spd
nicht kalt lassen und das wird auch die
entwicklung in der spd beeinflussen
sodass sie das kommunizierende röhren
sind die beiden ehemaligen volksparteien
wer wird das noch sein am ende das wird
auch disziplinieren und natürlich wird
auseinandersetzungen geben das ist eine
in einer demokratischen partei auf allen
seiten immer so gewesen aber die
alternative wäre aus der regierung zu
fliehen und hinzuschmeißen und dann
unterzugehen ich glaube dass selbst die
jungen leute das nicht wollen können und
wollen werden und man muss ja einst auch
noch sehen die grüne fraktion ist
mindestens so links und mindestens so
jung wie die spd-fraktion da gibt es
viele gemeinsamkeiten
da wird es dann das problem seien die
fdp mit so nehmen aber ich glaube nicht
dass das in erster linie ein problem der
spd sein wird gut also wenn wir da vor
allen dingen zwei fraktionen haben mit
eher linker ausrichtung in einer
zukünftigen amtlich ihm jetzt mal der
spot von hugo müller-vogg auf was
sozialdemokratie früher sagten die
belastbarkeit der wirtschaft testen
übertragen auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen ist dass die
belastbarkeit von christian lindner
testen der natürlich da ein korrektiv
sein wird wenn das wirklich so linke die
fraktionen sind oder mit einem starken
linken akzent welche erfolgsaussichten
hat denn dann eine ampelkoalition also
überhaupt das ist zu einer kommt ja also
ich denke politisch ist es für christian
lender interessanter in ampel zu gehen
als in jamaica weil ich glaube er kann
in der ampel auch sich als
aushängeschild für stabile finanzen für
ordentliche wirtschaftspolitik
präsentieren er kann das viel stärker
mache also dass in jamaika machen könnte
weil da ja schon diese rolle dann die
union für sich beanspruchen würden also
er könnte sich viel mehr profilieren
und ich glaube auch einfach dass
christian linden auch viel mehr lust hat
mit der spd und den grünen das zu machen
er kann natürlich jetzt nicht so schnell
einfach umschwenken weil er hat ja in
nrw auch mit der union zusammen regiert
und er kann nicht einfach sagen okay
dann gehe ich dann darüber so dass ich
schon glaube dass man ernsthaft auch
über jamaika sprechen wird durch die
größere chance aber eindeutig auch aus
sicht der fdp bei der ampel liegt mit
dem fox sehen sie das ähnlich das
christian lindner da wirklich
tatsächlich lieber in einer ampel ist
weil er mit einer führung schwachen und
vielleicht auch gelegentlich in zukunft
irrlichternden union im moment zumindest
das nichts anfangen kann und ich glaube
für die entscheidung der fdp ist nicht
die frage des zustandes des
koalitionspartners das aufgegeben
sondern die frage was im
koalitionsvertrag steht was ich mit
ihren eigenen dingen durchsetzen können
aber ich glaube da ist natürlich in
einer ganz starken position denn dadurch
das ist rechnerisch für rot rot grün
nicht reicht das ist ja für olaf scholz
einerseits ein nachteil er kann
sozusagen der fdp nicht die
folterwerkzeuge zeigen und sagen wir
gehen nicht mitmacht dann mach es mit
der linken was die fdp in eine
schwierige situation gebracht hätte man
dann viele wirtschaftskreise und leute
die ihr nahestehen gesagt hätten also
jetzt sei doch bei den steuern bisschen
flexibler bevor wir rot-rot-grün
gegenmacht eintrag kompromisse das fällt
weg auf der anlage auf der anderen seite
ist ein vorteil für schon weil der linke
flügel gar nicht sagen kann aber wir
müssen auch mit den linken rät aber
diese situation spielt eigentlich der
fdp in die hände und lindner kann das
ausnutzen wie gesagt er muss aber an
seinen leitplanken festhalten er kann
nicht ein koalitionsvertrag
unterschreiben wohin der ja die eigene
partei die eigenen wähler sagen
so haben wir nicht gewettet dafür habe
ich nicht gewählt und das hat schon ein
paar punkte drin
mindestlohn 12 euro im jahr 2022 ja oder
nein da gibt es keinen kompromiss sieht
das machen wir bis 25 denn dann muss er
stolz sagen heute ich habe euch vor der
wahl versprochen und da werden wieder
seine eigenen linien nicht mitmachen
also das wird alles sehr komplizierte
geschichte und vielleicht finden die
dreier ein weg dass man sagt sozusagen
im sozialen ist die spd der tonangebende
bei der klimapolitik
grünen und bei wirtschaft und finanzen
er die fdp es oder art österreichische
lösung dass man jedem einen bereich gibt
auf dem er sozusagen zeigen kann was für
ihn besonders wichtig ist und die
anderen sachen daneben in gewisser weise
akzeptiert
werden wir wieder steigen weil es ich
glaube überhaupt nicht dass das lindner
mehr lust hat auf eine ampelkoalition
wenn er sich das aussuchen könnte dann
würde er am liebsten nur mit der cdu csu
koalieren aber
trotzdem ist das finde ich ein kühner
ansatz zu sagen da wird die fdp
sichtbarer also dadurch dass das die
differenz da einfach größer ist ja aber
der weg wäre ja viel kürzer in einer
jamaika-koalition weil dann doch die die
überschneidungen einfach da mehr
vorhanden sind und man zieht es jetzt ja
auch schon in den vor sondierungen
zwischen grünen und fdp das da glaube
ich sind die hürden nicht so groß wie
zwischen spd und fdp da gibt es ja schon
einige
kompromissbereitschaft signale auch aber
eben auch
nach hat man ja gesagt worden ist
lindner kann sich an der ampel
eigentlich mehr profilieren sind jamaika
und möglicherweise bekannte aus der
ampel oder aus der spd das gleiche raus
verhandeln die aus der union
letztendlich im koalitionsvertrag dass
ich mir auch google talk hat ja gesagt
er seiner starken position in der tat
ist ja auch ohne ihn gibt es keinen
kanzler scholz beziehungsweise der
müssten als alternative in die
ungeliebte co og ja gut aber ich meine
die fdp es ja auch stark unter zugzwang
klar an die jetzt eine recht starke
verhandlungsposition
aber wenn sie das jetzt platzen lassen
das kann das kann die fdp sich nicht
leisten nach den nach den erfahrungen
von 2017 und warum sollte also es ist
jetzt ich finde der punkt ist ein
bisschen ein anderer in der
jamaika-koalition in der option einer
jamaika-koalition dass nach diesem
wahlergebnis der union daraus einen
regierungsauftrag abgeleitet werden
könnte das natürlich auch recht
abenteuerlich so eine partei auch
weitgehend jetzt abgerückt von dieser
position ja aber den verhandlungsauftrag
heißt es ja gut dann kann man natürlich
einfach ich hätte gerne schritte geld
noch einen anderen aspekt muss einen
das darf ja auch jede partei von sich
behaupten sie hat einen
verhandlungsauftrag ob es dazu kommt
werden wir sehen schmiergeld lange
weißen der spd ja so dass der
pragmatismus
sollte dann sag ich jetzt mal als
schlagwort es schwer hatte gegen die
gegen das parteiprogramm das ändert sich
jetzt möglicherweise auch unter dem
zwang der verhältnisse andererseits ist
es ja auch so in vier jahren muss die
spd ja rechenschaft ablegen von ihren
wählern was sie alles zu wege gebracht
hat in einer koalition und da wird man
dann nach der sozialdemokratischen
handschrift suchen wollen uns suchen
müssen kann es sein dass olaf scholz die
zugeständnisse dann machen muss die ihm
möglicherweise dann auf die füße fallen
wie die union ist ja in den letzten
jahren mit der spd auch hatte da hatte
man ja viel von sozialdemokratische
handschrift gesprochen in einer
koalition wo die union der sehr viel
stärker wahr sehen sie da eine gefahr
für die spd
gut bei kompromissen gibt es immer die
gefahr dass die eine seite sagt das ist
uns so weit und die andere sagt dass uns
nicht weit genug aber wenn das thema
pragmatismus von ihnen jetzt in den
vordergrund gestellt wird ich glaube die
spd hat in dieser regierung in vielen
punkten pragmatismus gezeigt genauso wie
die union
und das wird auch diese neue regierung
wenn sie denn eine ampel sein sollte
auszeichnen ob das am ende dann
für die linken in der spd oder auch für
menschenrechtler für umwelt schützen
eine spd ausreicht ist eine andere frage
aber wenn diese regierung erfolgreich am
ende da steht und vier jahre
durchgehalten hat und vieles umgesetzt
hat dann kann das wie merkel das auch
gemacht hat olaf scholz sich auf seine
fahnen schreiben und der kanzler ist
dann immer noch derjenige der auch die
meriten einheimst
das ist in der spd sicherlich
schwieriger zu vermitteln und auch nach
außen schwieriger zu kommunizieren als
das in der union war aber in der union
war ja auch in den letzten jahren kaum
noch diskussion und kaum noch wirklich
alternativen und und profilierung zu
sehen gegenüber der kanzlerin das muss
eine lebendige demokratie aushalten und
ich setze mal darauf dass das bei den
grünen genauso sein wird also wird das
auch nicht das alleinstellungsmerkmal
der spd seien dann über die ergebnisse
einer solchen regierung zu diskutieren
noch kaum anzunehmen dass die spd zu
einem schweige orten montiert wenn wir
jetzt bei uns angesehen die personelle
aufstellung wir haben ja sie haben
diesen flyer angesprochen auf der einen
seite ist kevin kühnert der verteiler in
seinem wahlkreis auf der anderen olaf
scholz ist ein schönes symbol
bleibt denn kevin kühnert trotz einer
möglichen kanzlerschaft von olaf scholz
der starke mann in der spd die obwohl
die harfe habe nicht ganz passt graue
eminenz
man sagt ja also der heimliche vorsehen
welche wie seine rolle jetzt unter einer
wirklichen kanzlerschaft olaf scholz
aussehen naja wird ja schon unter denen
jusos die das recht wie wir ja schon
diskutiert haben recht stark vertreten
sind schon eine führende rolle einnehmen
und die stehen sicher geschlossen hinter
ebenso wie die gesamte partei linke
darauf steht aber ich denke wir dürfen
das nicht zu statisch sehen ist hat
wirklich es ist was passiert im letzten
jahr und diese starken fronten zwischen
scholz und der linken die haben haben
sich angenähert ich glaube auch es war
eine voraussetzung
eigentlich im nachhinein gesehen dafür
dass es eine linke partei führung gab
mit kevin kühnert
nach der anderen seite scholz so als
mitte politiker dass scholz überhaupt
gewonnen hat wenn scholz gekommen wäre
und hätte gesagt so ich mache jetzt hier
dieses programm werde er bei vielen
eigenen parteigenossen gar nicht so
angekommen dann hätten die ihn nicht
gewählt deswegen glaube ich diese diese
annäherung von der mitte und den linken
ist noch eine voraussetzung dafür
also das ist bestehen bleibt und dass
die eingebunden werden und dass sie sich
wiederfinden mit verschiedenen projekten
ist eine voraussetzung dafür dass er das
überhaupt durchhalten kann
das heißt müller
keller ja ich hab ich nämlich noch einen
satz kevin kühnert hat am montag am
sonntagabend nach ende der offiziellen
veranstaltung in einem kleineren kreis
der oben im vierten stock war gesagt ich
stehe dafür dass die disziplin die wir
jetzt hatten auch in den vier jahren so
weit wie möglich umgesetzt wird ob das
jetzt fishing for compliments war
jedenfalls hat er es gesagt dafür gibt
es mehrere zeugen und ich denke mal er
wird bemüht sein und das hat man auch in
den diskussionen gesehen ob das bei
markus lanz war in anderen sendungen
dass er
gespürt hat was für eine verantwortung
er hat und also die bereit ist auch
wahrzunehmen müller von der 18-monatigen
oder 24 monatigen frist von sigmar
gabriel gesprochen halten sie es für
ausgeschlossen dass es
zu einer jetzt wie klaus peter schmidt
der gelder skizziert hat längeren ja ich
weiss nicht burgfrieden oder integration
einverständnis in der spd bleibt was ja
dann möglicherweise den politischen
erfolg der partei auch noch in die
zukunft verlängert
also in diesen politischen zeiten wo
auch die politische stimmung innerhalb
kurzer zeit so schnell umschlagen kann
ist recht schwierig prognosen zu machen
was in den nächsten vier jahren ist das
hängt auch davon ab was noch an äußeren
einflüssen kommt für welche aufgaben
sich regierung gestellt sieht die
letzten bundesregierung und hatten wir
immer die ganz großen probleme die alle
nicht im koalitionsvertrag regelt waren
sondern die eben durch euro-krise corona
andere dinge
von außen sieht zum handeln gezwungen
haben oder ist auch über die frage wie
handelt eine regierung das also insoweit
ist das ist das recht schwierig die
erste große hürde ist der
koalitionsvertrag und es ist völlig
richtig dass olaf scholz und die linke
sich inhaltlich sehr stark angenähert
haben das programm ist ein linkes
spd-programm
agenda 2010 gg inzwischen gehören als
neoliberales teufelszeug in den reihen
der spd aber wie viel kann er dadurch
durchsetzen gegen die fdp und gegen die
grünen das dass wir die entscheidende
frage sei und davon hängt es ab wie der
stadt ist natürlich wird am anfang die
display groß genug sein um ihn zum
kanzler zu werden aber dann in den
niederungen des alltags wenn wenn die
gesetze gemacht werden jetzt heißt ja
hätten wir halt darauf bestanden dass
das kommt und da hat sie wieder die fdp
durchgesetzt und wie sollen wir das
unseren leuten die den wahlkreisen
erklärt und dann dann dann wird
schwieriger und dann muss man sehen
jahre regiert ist bis jetzt sehr
diskutieren es gibt auch äußerungen aus
der fraktion wieder sagen ohne die jusos
hat die ordnung keine mehrheit das muss
man auch sehr gut jetzt gibt es ja frau
bethke gibt es ja den den offensichtlich
erkennbaren versucht der spd möglichst
schnell in sondierungsgespräche zu
kommen da steckt vielleicht im
hinterkopf auch die überlegung solange
die union noch in solchen
schwierigkeiten ist nicht dass ich
nochmal berappelt und es dann
schwieriger wird man will ratz fatz
verhandeln also ganz schnell man will
auch nicht so detailliert
konvolute
zusammenbringen um einen
koalitionsvertrag dann letztendlich zu
verabschieden
ist das dann muss man auch nicht so
viele kompromisse schließen ist das eine
möglichkeit vielleicht auch eine solche
koalitionsbildung zu erleichtern wenn
nicht jedes detail jeder spiegelstrich
viel früher dargelegt ja unbedingt also
ich glaube da wäre auch ein pragmatismus
gefordert weil eigentlich keiner ein
interesse daran haben kann dass sich das
jetzt wieder monate hinzieht sondern
alle wollen möglichst schnell eine
regierung bilden und dann mit den mit
den kleinsten details anzufangen ist ja
nicht besonders ratsam wenn man
irgendwie vorankommen möchte und ich bin
da eigentlich nicht so skeptisch dass
das auch gelingen wird ich finde dann er
und ich finde es auch alles so spannend
weil es eine neue politische dynamik im
ganzen system plötzlich ergibt weil
diese koalitions bündnisse neu sind weil
das nachdenken auch der bürger über
eigene parteipolitische
präferenzen nochmal ganz durcheinander
gebracht wird und ich glaube dass das
ist erstmal gut das ist etwas sehr
lebendiges die ganzen schwierigkeiten
fürchte ich fangen erst an wenn die
regierung dann steht also was ich eben
schon erwähnt hatte mit der
selbstfindung der sozialdemokratie sie
da ganz große probleme und ganz viel
konfliktpotenzial und wenn kevin kühn
hat jetzt sagt er sorge für disziplin
dann ist das strategisch klug aber auch
etwas durchsichtig das ist ja überhaupt
keine garantie dass es dann so bleiben
wird wir können es alle nicht in die
zukunft gucken aber
also einfach wird das glaube ich nicht
schmittel sie als spd in seite die
partei gut kennt sie haben gerade gesagt
dass kevin kühnert da
in der wahlnacht nochmal klar gemacht
hat an ihm gescheitert nichts er will da
kein sand ins getriebe streuen gehen wir
mal von den szenario aus also es gibt
eine ampelkoalition olaf scholz wird
bundeskanzler die union ist mit sich
selbst beschäftigt liegt wurden keine
große gefahr mit dem bundesrat kann man
viele gesetzgebungs maßnahmen auch
durchbringen käme könnte olaf scholz
irgendwann mal auf die idee zu kommen
aus um seine macht abzusichern nachdem
er jetzt so fest im sattel sitzt auch
nach dem spd parteivorsitz zu greifen
warum sollte er das modell was jetzt
seit zwei jahren passiert ist ja was was
ihnen nicht daran gehindert hat
erfolgreich zu sein und wenn die
parteivorsitzenden die partei so führen
dass diese konflikte die er in der tat
drohen können dass die ausgeglichen
werden und dass die
in der partei sozusagen
geglättet geglättet werden bevor es ins
kabinett geht dann ist das doch eine
arbeitsteilung die ihm zupass kommt und
wenn man die aufgaben eines
bundeskanzler sieht und ich habe das ja
in jahren der rot grünen regierung auch
von innen erlebt dann ist das eine
mammutaufgabe da muss man sich nicht
gerade mit einer widerspenstigen
parteien vielen dingen beschäftigen und
das ist ein modell was glaube ich eher
nicht aufheben muss es sei denn es gibt
den versuch einer palastrevolte wohl die
machtfrage stellen muss okay dann muss
er das tun dann muss er nach dem
parteivorsitz greifen aber erstmal sich
das überhaupt dem entnehme ich dass der
parteivorsitz in der spd nicht mehr so
wichtig ist
das würde ich unterstreichen zumal das
jahr zwei sind nicht nur noch eine
person also da müssen auch zwei
sozusagen gegen einen agieren denn da an
widerspruch zwischen parteiführung und
kanzler gäbe und norbert wolter bei uns
war lange genug ich kenne ihn seit
vielen jahren als wir beide in zwei
verschiedenen landesregierungen aktiv
waren in nordrhein-westfalen nicht in
hessen ist ein realer und kein linker
in dem klassischen sinne der spd also da
wird dann erstmal der streit zwischen
festen und norbert walter borjans
zu treffen sollen aber vielleicht gibt
es ja auch noch eine geheime option ich
habe spaßeshalber gesagt wenn man/frau
es ging gut realisieren will dann macht
man sich jetzt zur bundestagspräsidentin
aber das ist zugegebenermaßen anschaffen
will jetzt zu viel der
ich glaube der parteilose da ist schon
noch wichtig dass wir anders wichtig ich
glaube die die aufgabe der
parteivorsitzenden ist jetzt ein anderer
als vorher hintergrund meine frage war
gewesen angela merkel hat ja sonst als
sie den parteivorsitz abgegeben hat eben
eigentlich im prinzip verlassen dass
beide sind an der hand gehört wenn ich
mich richtig erinnere hat helmut schmidt
danach als es zu spät war bedauert nicht
auch gleichzeitig parteivorsitzende dazu
seien gerhard schröder war ja
vorübergehend parteivorsitzender daran
dass wieder abgegeben das war sozusagen
der anfang vom ende gewesen gehört dass
auf mittlere und längere sicht zusammen
der parteivorsitz und die kanzlerschaft
also als macht technischen gründen
glaube ich habe gehört ist auf jeden
fall zusammen das wird natürlich dem
kanzler oder der kanzlerin dann eine
größere macht geben wenn so wenn die
partei direkt dahinter stehen würde ich
glaube aber dass es keine option ist für
den zustand in dem die spd ist also wie
sich das entwickelt wenn die koalition
gut läuft wenn norbert walter borjans
glaube ich gar nicht mehr will nicht
noch einmal antreten will und dass
fristen ministerin wird oder
bundestagspräsidentin was ich wiederum
nicht glaube weil sie keine person ist
die jetzt integriert sind und er doch
auch einen widerspenstigen charakter hat
also ich glaube wenn die beiden nicht
mehr wollen das dann noch mal die frage
neu gestellt wird aber jetzt nach dem
vorsitz greifen da ich glaube das wäre
unklug was meinen sie das wird
der mögliche kanzler und scholz tun mit
der partei bilder sie das wäre ja eine
möglichkeit
mögliche differenzen zwischen seiner
partei seiner kanzlerschaft zu
überbrücken
das vermag ich nicht so richtig zu sagen
ich würde aber noch in widersprechen
oder also zumindest hinzufügen was weil
sie norbert walter borjans als real
bezeichnet haben der hat immerhin
richtung der fdp von einer voodoo
ökonomie gesprochen das bin ich jetzt
also das sind ja auch ein hammerwerk
auch gemacht dass du dass das sind ja
gut aber dass das sind natürlich töne
die jetzt auch vielleicht nicht so
hilfreich sollten sie haben hier ein
toller paraden aber was interessiert
mich mein geschwätz von gestern
[Gelächter]
aber ich bin das ist interessant dass
sie das sagen dass da dass der
spd-vorsitzende mehr so viel zähle in
meiner wahrnehmung ist es schon dass so
dass das was hier ist das bild der spd
schon sehr mitgeprägt hat also es ist
jetzt nicht dass das vollkommen im
hintergrund ist und daran entzündeten
sich ja auch sehr viele debatten und
sehr viel kritik auch in vielen ihrer
äußerungen
also es hat mich hat mich gerade ein
bisschen überrascht dass er bei 3 die
außenwahrnehmung glaube ich ein bisschen
eine andere was jetzt die färbung der
partei betrifft ich glaube fast gehabt
das bild schon geprägt aber teilweise
auch negativ geprägt ja ja das ist so
lange bei 15 prozent verharrte da habe
sie geschüttelt maß an verantwortung
dafür und der auf die content scholz bei
aller
hochachtung vor diesem perfekt perfekten
wahlkampf ohne die vielen fehler die die
cdu gemacht hatte ja praktisch kein
fettnäpfchen ausgelassen hat völlig
zerstritten war weiß ich nicht ob der
wald sich auch so ausgefallen wäre ganz
abgesehen davon muss man auch mal sehen
auch wenn die spd zurzeit so auftritt
also wer sie kurz oder der absolute
mehrheit
25,7 prozent sind zusammen mit den 25,7
von peer steinbrück nach wie vor das
zweitschlechteste in der geschichte der
spd wenn ich da kurz ein hagens darf das
habe ich nämlich also die einordnung ich
finde die 27 25 7 sind deutlich mehr als
damals merkel hatte als sie gewonnen hat
gegen schröder und ist auch deutlich
mehr bei stoiber schröder und
ich habe
30 entschuldigung merkel hatte für zwei
unterschiedliche dinge über die
zweitstimmen anzahl oder denkt aber was
ich sagen wollte genau stein
lustigerweise wegen andere sachen
geredet ich glaube scholz hat 720.000
stimmen mehr als steigen damals gut na
gut man sei weiter gewachsen
wählerschaft also das ist gut aber wenn
wir zahlen jetzt hier anfangen gut also
die meisten wahlsieger an die ich mich
erinnern kann in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten sind häufig zustande
gekommen weil nicht weil der wahlsieger
so toll sondern die gegner und die
wahlverlierer so schlecht disponiert
waren ein erfolgreicher müller vogg sie
haben ja vorhin gesagt
oder ihr zweifel an der ampel koalition
dass die zustande kommt kommt auch daher
dass eben die jusos tag war sie eine art
sperrminorität haben dass also ohne die
jusos ist keine ampel koalition keine
mehrheit gibt jetzt könnte man das ja
etwas abschwächen in der argumentation
und sagen weil die ampel koalition im
bundestag eine ziemlich große mehrheit
hat könnte ja der ein oder andere linke
aus der grünen oder aus der spd-fraktion
auch mal der gegenstimmen ohne dass die
regierung stürzt ist das möglicherweise
eine eine strategie die dieser möglichen
ampelkoalition dann innewohnt dass sich
die mütter vorteil wenn ich eine
ausreichende mehrheit habe dass sie sich
ein paar abweichler haben kann die aus
gewissensgründen aus innenpolitischen
gründen auch blick auf die besonderen
interessen gruppen die sie verdrehen
also ich war das politische interessen
kommen dass die dann auch mal abweichen
stimmen deswegen gibt es ja die große
streit was ist besser der knappe
mehrheit die disziplinierte oder eine
große mehrheit die dazu neigt zum
abweichen dass viele abweisen wir haben
in der letzte große koalition gesehen
auch bei der cdu wo in der euro-frage
viele von der offiziellen linie
abgewichen sind ohne dass deshalb die
mehrheit gefährdet habe dass das dass
wir es immer geben nur die jusos in
einer starken position und die werden
schon darauf achten dass er im
koalitionsvertrag dass einige ist angles
drin sind die wissen das sind ja auch
realisten wie wir sie auch dass ich ihr
verteilt vorgaben nicht eins zu eins
umsetzen können aber ein paar dinge
müssen drin stehen und da muss dann die
neue irgendwie nachgeben und muss seinen
leuten erklärt das ist noch lange noch
lange nicht in trockenen tüchern
schmiergeldern olaf scholz bei einer
ausreichenden mehrheit für die ampel
koalition da auch etwas mehr freiraum
lassen so etwas eine art anti autoritäre
ag tüte
werden bei dem einen oder anderen der
sagt ich kann jetzt aus gewissensgründen
da nicht mitstimmen steht zwar im
koalitionsvertrag drin aber mit meinem
gewissen ist das nicht vereinbar ist
dass so eine denkbare strategie das auch
so zu handeln dass eben nicht so
wahnsinnig bindende zwingende
fraktionsdisziplin herrscht
also das war immer so dass es bei
gewissen auch grundsätzlichen dingen
abweichungen gab in allen fraktionen
auch in der unionsfraktion
von daher würde ich das niemals
ausschließen aber ich denke wenn es um
grundsätzliche um strategische dinge
geht und um zukunftsfragen die in diesem
land entschieden werden müssen dann muss
er eine wirklich ausreichende mehrheit
sicherstellen und man kann nicht bei
jeder abstimmung abweichler in kauf
nehmen also diesen
erziehungsauftrag muss dann die
fraktionsführung haben und nicht umsonst
ist hoffentlich ja mit fast 100 prozent
wiedergewählt worden weil er auch der
typ ist und derjenige ist der einen
solchen erziehungsauftrag dann für die
jungen land wahrnehmen kann aber auch
ich glaube es hilft jetzt nichts den
jusos
dauernd zuzuschreiben dass sie alles
regieren würden ich glaube da ist auch
ein lernprozess möglich und wenn man den
user olaf scholz sieht und den heutigen
kanzlerkandidaten und möglichen kanzler
minister ein langer weg und ein langer
lernprozess
und er hat auch von seinen job als
generalsekretär über arbeitsminister als
hamburger bürgermeister natürlich viele
stationen durchgemacht und eine
regierungsfraktion die lernt das ist ein
lernprozess mit jedem gesetz werden
diskussionen geführt in den
arbeitskreisen dann in den ausschüssen
und so weiter und die jungen werden
lernen und sie werden lernen dass man
nicht mit dem kopf durch die wand kann
dass ein parlamentarischer kompromiss
eben ein kompromiss sein muss und da bin
ich nicht wirklich jetzt
besorgt oder unruhig dass das nicht
gelingen kann es wird sicherlich dann
bei einzelnen punkten sei es nato sei es
außenpolitik was menschenrechte angeht
harte diskussionen geben und
möglicherweise auch gegenstände
schuldigen wir müssen weiter an der
stelle jetzt abbrechen sie haben diese
aufgabe jetzt dankenswerterweise
übernommen das alles aufzuzählen für die
jusos hat so habe ich sie jetzt
verstanden gilt auf jeden fall der satz
von olaf scholz lernen heißt siegen
lernen das heißt eines tages wenn man
lernprozess durchgemacht hat auch mal
bundeskanzler zu werden ich bedanke mich
bei cerstin gammelin bei hanna bei hugo
müller vogg und bei klaus peter schmidt
die liebe zuschauer am samstag um 18 uhr
kommt unser bürgertag wir müssen reden
dieses mal zum thema wie hat die
flutkatastrophe unser land geändert
betroffene aus dem tal kommen zu wort am
samstag um 18 uhr bringen wir diesen
bürger talk hier zur sendung aus dernau
im aatal jetzt folgt felix der tag mit
constantia trotzki thema heute unter
anderem auch natürlich sortierungen und
sondierungen der politik in berlin zur
regierungsbildung bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]